paulo espino takes the field with his
teammates 30-second appearance this year
it'll be his 16th start
and jazz rips a base it into right field
no one out knock for
chisholm junior
marlins have their first hit and first
base runner tonight good start for jazz
the marlins here in the first
the marlins have two on
for
one of their hottest hitters certainly
in terms of the power he's homered in
three straight games
3-1 pitch to sanchez
right down the middle and another base
hit soto comes up throwing jazz around
third and he's in there nrbi for jesus
sanchez a good start for the marlins
as three consecutive batters have
reached and they're in business with him
on the corners and one out
up the middle should be two garcia
couldn't ask for anything better than
that
now the best version of sandy alcantara
has been on display for the last month
and changed this will be his 30th start
of the year number 75 of his career
well he had 14 as last time and that's
his first tonight
ground ball gets up on jazz but he
sticks with it makes the play a one two
three first inning for sandy
one nothing marlons
de la cruz walked first down
yeah he lifted up a little bit and
reachable then he drops it into right
he's going for two good throws gonna get
him
and juan soto makes a good throw
that was a good throw you called it good
throw gets him good throw got him great
play by juan soto one hopper right on
the money thanks for coming
sadie alcandra back to work for the
bottom of the third inning
but he still has so much left in the
tank late and maybe it's because he's
been so efficient on 22 outs tonight or
22 pitches rather he's got seven outs
one out and luis garcia
hits one out to left field in the air
for brinson
and there are two way
he's got himself
his second strikeout another one two
three inning for sandy who has looked
fantastic again tonight
jesus sanchez
one swing the difference in the game
that ball was well hit to left yadiel a
long way to go
twisting and turning he gathers it in
he's shown that he can make not only the
routine play but the tough play this is
not easy that ball is tailored back
toward the foul pole on the warning
track up against the wall nice play how
about this the nationals are going to
walk the bases loaded they had an open
base it happened to be third
but they are going to walk east sandias
to bring up sandy alcatra
brilliant move what a manager best move
ever
five strikeouts for paulo the marlins
have stranded five three balls and two
strikes
two outs nobody on here in the fourth
inning sandy had 45 pitches
and here it comes
ground ball to first for leiwan diaz
sandy
twisted something
maybe sandy trying to get off the mound
to cover first base on a ground ball to
the right side gingerly walking off the
mound ah okay there you go so it hit off
of sandy
and then redirected to lewin diaz
sandy alcantara emerged from the marlins
dugout but he also emerged with manager
don mattingly pitching coach mel
sotomayor jr and hen athletic trainer
gene basham
and it looks like sandy has passed the
test
they will keep a close eye on sandy who
brings home a 3-2 pitch
and he got bell to chase 99.
third strikeout for alcantara
and there's one out in the fifth
base runners or no base runners hits or
no hits
he's trying to protect a one nothing
lead he's got two outs in the fifth
inning
ground ball esan's got it
sets his feet
and gets the out
five perfect innings so far for sandy
carlos meadow ready to go back to work
oh look at that hop picked off by garcia
who practices that play during batting
practice he does
he must
nice play louie and zendale contra
perfect through
five innings
sharply hit jazz is there
and loses his footing
and that is the first base runner for
the nationals tonight
i would think they're going to give him
an error
it would not be the clean hit
scorers are often looking for for the
first knock
one tipped and caught by jackson so
another strikeout that is four
for sandy
and he gets the strikeout of thomas
so he's through six innings
nationals have had a base runner
that's been it
escobar soto and bell here in the
seventh inning a one-nothing
marlins lead that run scored in the
first
this one is
softly popped shallow right for sanchez
to make the play
he has yet to reach base tonight as
sandy retires him and there are two outs
in the seventh inning
and josh bell
over his head off the wall
six and two thirds no hit innings for
sandy alcantara
but he will not
join the history books tonight
but splendid nonetheless
hell this is a breaking ball
and again i think this is probably
respecting bell as much as anything
because we haven't seen too many
breaking balls that have looked like
that tonight
another payoff pitch and he got him to
chase
strikeout number six
for sandy he's through seven
he's given up a hit but he's still
dominating the nationals
right side who's going to get to the
back to cover austin volton plenty of
time
donnie might need a crowbar to get the
ball from sandy tonight that's been the
case as of late
and there's the strikeout of kibum
his seventh and there's one down in the
eighth
here is ruiz
and ruiz a fly ball out to center field
coming in de la cruz
luis garcia
and he goes after the first one sends it
high in the air out towards center but
de la cruz is there and on six pitches
sandy gets through the eighth inning
i see him again in the ninth
two in scoring position nobody out in
the ninth as they look for more runs
and jackson rips one to left field that
is off the wall
that'll bring home two and alex jackson
into second with a double
helping out his battery mate with two
huge runs in the ninth inning to give
sandy some breathing room it's three to
nothing
eight innings
one hit
no walks and seven strikeouts
for sandy tonight he gives way to dylan
floro
if it gets that far
oh what a play
what a play all around issan diaz with a
slick play jazz with a great turn and
the pick
by leighwood
i'd be willing to bet this is the
fanciest double play you're going to see
all night around major league baseball
here's a 1-2 from floro
and a ground ball up the middle right
behind the bag miggy makes the throw
it's a marlins win
and it started
with sandy
dominant performance tonight flirted
with a perfect game was perfect through
five had a no-hitter through six
you